sounds like you're signaling to me we're
ready to talk about this right as you
can see and I think this is really
important for for places where it's like
oh I can just kind of think of this the
working out that you have is less
important right but the reason why can't
we kind of sort of warming you up on
this
is the business situations where you can
think about it intuitively but we want
to give you these structures for the
situations where you can't just think in
your brain like here's what it is you
need some working out to sort of provide
a scaffold for your thinking okay so if
you haven't already please provide some
working here I'm talking about this new
known condition so I'm calling it k2
because I used k1 before six or seven is
what you know so again I'm going to
diagrammatically represent that here now
we've got the set notation right a
little bit
yep yes not at me none of me or shake at
me I just wanted to get something okay
good right remember set notation so this
idea before of talking about how the
favourable events change we actually
have notation to represent this right
what we're saying is our event it's
happening at the same time as this other
known information that's what this means
right that's how that changes so we have
language we have notation symbols for
when two things are happening and we
want to consider them simultaneously
when there's an overlap between them
then remember which symbol would be
appropriate here have a thing with two
things overlap we have fancy word here
the start with a tie it's intersection
very good so we've got this upside down
curvy you looking thing right so what
we're thinking about here is well how
many ways because I kind of consider all
the favor lends me more only some of
them right how many ways can our
favorable of it overlap with the
condition right and you can actually
physically see it up here okay which
situation is the only one that actually
matches what would I what would I
actually write down here which events is
is it that I'm interested in it's just
the seventh right it's just the seventh
right and I'm putting it in in inverted
commas because it's not a number like
this is how big it is it's an event it's
the name of an event like Queen weighs
right so I can say what is my what is my
size of my samples my sample size and
what's my size of my favorable event I'm
gonna write both of them right
of k2 is going to be there's there's
eight there's there's four of these and
four of these right so that's gonna be
eight I can also do the size of this new
this intersection is overlap right it's
time to get a little bit thick with all
of these symbols but it's so much
actually faster to write this there to
say all of the language and words that
go with describing this right we said
that was four
there are only four sevens right so if
when you wrote down your probability and
all right this is the probability of our
event if we know here comes that symbol
right that this is the condition then it
should be just four over eight which is
I'm gonna write that down whoops that's
a infinity sign which is not what I
wanted forever which is of course the
half that very many of you got so well
done if you got there okay one more time
let's have a look and this time I want
to see if we can develop this in a
generalized way because these are all
specific examples okay
so Part D I think we're we've got a bit
more ahead on this we can talk through
it together right so Part D says now you
have a look and you know it's not a
three four seven nine or ten yeah did I
get the numbers right yep not three four
seven others head so I'm going to change
my sample space up here so I'm knocking
out three four seven nine and ten Yeah
right okay so what am I going to write
down well I'm gonna introduce I'm gonna
say let's call this my new node
information right I can say this in two
ways I can just say it the way they told
me it's not three four seven nine or ten
or I could stay in it a little more
positively which might help because I
stated everything positively on the
board so far so what are the actual
options I have have a look up on the
board ace to five six what I got next
eights okay and then all the court cards
seem to be okay said all right now the
reason why it's actually helpful to
write it like this is because it makes
it a bit easier to calculate my new
sample size I just take all of these and
after multiply by four because there are
four suits okay so these
my sample size is 32 very good
there are eight different kinds each of
which there are four of okay so that's
my new sample size that'll be on my
denominator now when I think about the
overlap between my original original
original favorable there and my new
sample space have a look what is the
overlap between them which options been
crossed out that was also green before
seven eight queen Ace King Jack okay
hold on a second wait a second
the favor love them right at the
beginning there's only one for this
whole question what did it include which
ones how do i mark it on the board
I marked it with the green stuff right
so the seven and eight
I do want but look at that seven do you
see I know that that can no longer be an
option so I'm sort of removing that from
the running okay it's really just the
green ones that I have not eliminated
eight Queen ace there's three of those
and how many you have each of those do I
have four so I think this should be
twelve right now I'm just going to write
that first it's the eight the ACE and
the Queen and so the number of those
like you just told me should be twelve
right there's a how many eighths and
aces and queens are there in a deck this
should be twelve right
assume you've got a good deck so now I
can say I can actually take or combine
all this right the probability of my
original favorable event if you know
that's what that bar means if you know
it's a bit too long that this is your
condition is new favorable events
divided by new sample space 12 and 32
what is that common denominator in
factor of four and go beam that's at
three on eight I believe there we go
okay so let's formalize this I'm going
to now put this all in symbols but we've
actually got most of it here to be
honest if you are considering write the
probability of some kind of event and
you have
kind of known conditions some
information that can be I'm guaranteed
right then the way that we would state
this new fraction is one of the things
that actually got on here right well
first of all at the sample size how is
that restricted that's the size of well
you're limited event right it's like I
know this I know this so I'm gonna limit
eight everything else that could have
possibly happened right you work out
that size in this case it was 32 and
then what's the other number I need to
work out yeah see this intersection here
this is the favor all then I need to
know what that is and then how many
there are of that and so that's why I
say em and the way I would write the
intersection is a and K happening at the
same time okay now what you'll find is
this exact formula more or less you'll
find it there just above the example
we've been looking at however I this is
just a personal thing if you like the
way it's written then that's fine they
use A's and B's instead of ease and K's
it's just a it's just a visual
difference I don't like a and B though
because when I learned this I could
never remember which one was a and which
one was B they just didn't mean anything
to me
whereas a is the event that you're
really focusing on if you wanted you
could call F for favourable right
whereas I put K for this is something
you know you know this to be true you've
seen it so hopefully that helps you
distinguish which one is which make
sense does anyone have any questions